americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 24
day 24 the biden administration they
still don't know how many americans
officially have been left behind and
there is zero plan to get them out while
these hostages were abandoned by joe
biden they have not been abandoned by
their fellow americans six charter
planes from great americans around the
country including retired special ops
officers on the ground risking their
lives and other private organizations
are now on the tarmac in an airport in
northern afghanistan they're ready to
take off carrying americans and our
allies to qatar according to various
reports these planes are now being
blocked by the taliban and others and
have been blocked in some cases for six
long days and even the u.s state
department is not helping the taliban is
apparently demanding a ransom payment
from the u.s government the state
department reportedly refusing to grant
approval for private evacuation flights
to land in other countries
that is insane not only is the biden
state department doing nothing to rescue
our fellow americans that they abandoned
now they are reportedly obstructing
private rescue missions by a lot of
retired ops guys special ops forces that
are willing to put their own lives at
risk to help the americans that he
abandoned the americans who were
supposed to board these planes they
showed up at the airport they forked
over their papers to the taliban and
once again tonight they are in hiding
now more vulnerable than ever one
unnamed person involved with this the
extraction efforts telling fox news
quote if one life is lost as a result of
this the blood is on the white house's
hands their blood is on their hands
adding quote it is not the taliban that
is holding this up as much as much as it
sickens me to say
it is the u.s government
this is so bad even democratic senator
huge liberal richard blumenthal
connecticut is blasting the
administration over their incompetence
uh are you okay with this ron claine
tony blinken
joe biden if you're awake susan rice is
this uh is this one of the contingencies
that you plan for also
or do you just not care that you abandon
americans and left them pretty much for
dead to fend for themselves that's right
under terrorist rule thankfully tonight
we have some good news to report out of
afghanistan there is an american mother
from texas her three children they were
rescued by a man named corey mills he
will join us on this program in a moment
and his private team of other military
vets in a successful cross-border
operation but now despite having no
involvement in the rescue mission guess
what biden administration they attempted
to take credit for something they had
nothing to do with according to the
state department the united states has
facilitated the safe departure of four
u.s citizens by overland wrote from
afghanistan
now the organizer of this rescue mission
is calling that statement a complete and
total lie the u.s government did nothing
to rescue these americans absolutely
nothing of course joe biden doesn't seem
to care about any of this because today
after a long weekend of getting as much
needed west and relaxation in delaware
well biden toured flood damage in new
york and new jersey at every stop he was
met by protesters carrying anti-biden
signs waving trump flags and demanding
accountability
over afghanistan and more but according
to joe biden everybody he thought was
happy to see him the view people that
were there take a look
none of them
were shouting
or complaining
every one of them
were thanking me as if it was something
special i mean sincerely that i was here
buried in arlington
2011 december 11th
for what he lost his life for one
now finally biden had to mention the
protesters but he accused them of being
ignorant of course biden made no mention
at all of afghanistan nothing about the
americans he abandoned nothing about
those being held hostage behind enemy
lines in northern afghanistan nothing at
all nothing about the billions of
equipment he left behind
instead he focused on a much more
pressing and urgent situation
climate change only problem for joe is
he's either too stupid or frankly too
impaired to speak coherently and we've
got the videotape evidence and of course
we'll let you decide
group i have standing with me led by
chuck schumer
and your
congresswoman is this your district
grace menu oh it's crisis
no end and have zero emissions
net emissions by 2050 by 2020 make sure
all our electricity is zero emissions
this summer alone communities
with over a hundred million americans
a hundred american americans call home
have been struck by extreme weather each
dollar we invest
every dollar we raise
a city block
by two feet
flood proof
power
stations
sanitations
remember every single day donald trump
was president the left the media mob
they pretended to be you know feigning
so much outrage embarrassed by a donald
trump tweet i'll take a mean tweet any
day over abandoning americans now
how humiliating think as an american as
you see this all unfold
how humiliating how embarrassing is all
of this you've got a repulsive
disgusting and preventable disgrace an
unmitigated disaster
all preventable we watched the taliban
on the march in the month of march and
in april and in may and in june and in
july when we could have safely evacuated
our own fellow americans all our allies
and all our military equipment that they
now have in their possession it is a
disgrace our allies around the world
they are shocked they are horrified and
america's enemies they're gloating and
they are completely emboldened and it's
not just the stammering and the
confusion from a man clearly in severe
cognitive decline but also this is
important we don't leave our fellow
americans behind
i can tell you this well hannity knows
donald trump i do
donald trump would have obliterated the
taliban if they made one wrong move just
like he did baghdadi and associates and
the al-qaeda leader in yemen and
solamani and destroyed the entire
caliphate in iraq and syria joe biden
did nothing as the taliban was on the
march and we knew it for months our
intel community didn't fail they warned
him every single day these documents
will be revealed we don't abandon
americans in hostile foreign countries
run by radical islamic extremists we
don't put the lives of our fellow
americans in their hands that is not who
we are supposed to be or who we are this
is not a partisan issue this isn't about
democrat republican conservative or
liberal if every american stuck by an
enemy lines as a liberal that wants to
get me fired i want them home trying to
get me fired this is about saving our
fellow americans lives one example a
pregnant woman now in hiding why she got
kicked in the stomach by a taliban
fighter while attempting to reach the
airport multiple times and she says that
americans are being hunted all over the
country we have more anecdotal stories
day in and day out according to
congressman daryl lysa there are at
least 500 americans who are still
trapped including multiple students from
northern california and if you add in
their family members guess what it's
over a thousand that need to be home
right here on american soil to make
matters worse get this for gitmo
detainees released by biden and obama in
exchange for remember bo bergdahl
bergdahl
they're now
senior taliban positions
this is a nightmare a hostage crisis on
a massive scale that will likely
continue
i don't even want to discuss my worst
fears here but think mogadishu think
about daniel pearl you know where i'm
headed
i pray to god that i am wrong i pray
that every one of these americans now
trapped behind enemy lines hostage gets
home safely but under this incompetent
president i frankly just fear the worst
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else